[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please rise and
welcome Cecilia Luis as she sings our
National Anthem
oh say can you see by the dawn's early
light what so proudly we hailed at the
twilight's last gleaming whose broad
stripes and bright stars through the
perilous fight or the ramparts we
watched were so gallantly streaming and
the Rockets bombs bursting in through
the night that our flag was still there
oh say does that star-spangled banner
[Music]
or the land of the free and the home
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome MIT
president Susan Hockfield
good afternoon and to our many visitors
welcome to MIT
president Obama has articulated a
powerful vision for restoring economic
growth creating jobs and counteracting
climate change by investing aggressively
in clean energy research and development
through the Recovery Act he accelerated
that vision and set forth a bold
challenge America's research
universities are responding to the
president's challenge and here through
the MIT Energy Initiative we're helping
to frame the national debate on energy
policy we're advancing the frontiers of
energy research we're educating a new
generation of energy pioneers and we're
turning our research into innovations
that will transform the way the world
gets its energy and will create new
industries in the process the president
obama has come to MIT to talk about
america's potential to lead in clean
energy is a tribute to the
groundbreaking work of our faculty and
students including many in this room
close to 20% of our faculty are engaged
in energy research and our students are
equally passionate the student-led MIT
energy Club has more than 1,700 members
brilliant young people preparing to
invent a sustainable energy future we
share President Obama's view that clean
energy is the defining challenge of this
era to meet the doubling of global
energy demand by 2050 to drive new
patents new products new industries and
new jobs and to mitigate climate change
clean energy is the only Avenue as we
carry out mi t--'s mission of service to
tackle humanity's great shared
challenges in the realm of clean energy
we thank Governor Patrick and Senator
Kerry here in Massachusetts for being
such effective champions of this cause
we're deeply grateful
and we're deeply grateful to President
Obama for visiting with us and for his
forceful support of federal funding for
energy R&D it's now my pleasure to
introduce the director of the MIT Energy
Initiative Ernest Moniz the Cecil and
Ida green professor of physics and
engineering systems
professor Moniz served in the Clinton
administration as Undersecretary of the
Department of Energy and currently
serves on President Obama's Council of
Advisors on science and technology
professor Moniz
[Applause]
well thank you Susan I thank you as well
for your vision and steadfast commitment
to marshaling the tremendous
intellectual resources of our faculty
and students to accelerate the clean
energy transformation like to also add
my welcome to Governor Patrick a clean
energy leader for our state and region
Senator Kerry for his leadership in
international affairs and climate
legislation and Congressman Capuano our
congressman for his able representation
and commitment to our to our agenda I
have the great pleasure and honor today
to introduce President Barack Obama
through his advancement of clean energy
science technology and innovation the
creative energy focus of the stimulus
package and critically important enhance
support of energy research and
development a sustained effort over the
next many years the president has
expanded our energy vision and is
focused on creating the conditions for
energy innovation to flourish across our
country at a faster pace at a scale
large enough to match the challenge the
President's commitment to integrating
sound science and critical analysis into
the formulation and implementation of
policy across the board is profoundly
important and indeed essential for
moving us to a sustainable energy future
the president has reestablished the
United States as a member of the
community of nations committed to
meeting the length challenges of climate
change economic development and security
President Obama's engagement with our
industrialized friends and allies with
the emerging economies which is China
India Brazil and Mexico and with the
developing world are all essential for a
global low-carbon future and underscore
his clear understanding that leadership
is best illustrated through example we
are privileged to welcome to the
Commonwealth and to MIT the president
the United States of America Barack
Obama
thank you so much
thank you
thank you very much thank you thank you
so much thank you everybody thank you
very much please have a seat thank you
thank you MIT I am hugely honored to be
here it's always been a dream of mine to
visit the most prestigious school in
Cambridge Massachusetts hold on a second
certainly the most prestigious School in
this part of Cambridge Massachusetts and
I'll probably be here for a while I
understand a bunch of engineering
students put my motorcade on top of
building 10 what this tell you something
about MIT everybody hands out periodic
tables what's up with that
I want to thank all of you today for the
warm welcome and for the work that all
of you are doing to generate and test
new ideas that hold so much promise for
our economy and for our lives and in
particular I want to thank two
outstanding MIT professors Eric Lander
and person you just heard from Ernie
Moniz for their service on my Council of
Advisors on science and technology and
they have been hugely helpful to us
already on looking at for example how
the federal government can most
effectively respond to the threat of the
h1n1 virus and so I'm very grateful to
them
we've got some other special guests here
I just want to acknowledge very briefly
first of all my great friend and a
champion of Science and Technology here
in the great Commonwealth of
Massachusetts my friend of all Patrick
is here
our lieutenant governor Tim Murray is
here
attorney General Martha Coakley is here
auditor of the Commonwealth Joe DiNucci
is here
the mayor of the great city of Cambridge
Denise Simmons is in the house
the mayor of Boston Tom Menino is not
here but he met me at the airport and he
is doing great
he sends best wishes somebody who really
has been an all-star in Capitol Hill Oh
over the last 20 years but certainly
over the last year on a whole range of
issues everything from Afghanistan to
clean energy great friend John Kerry
and a wonderful member of Congress I
believe this is your district is that
correct
Mike Mike Capuano please give Mike
now dr. Moniz is also the director of mi
t--'s energy initiative called mighty
and he and president Hockfield just
showed me some of the extraordinary
energy research being conducted at this
Institute windows that generate
electricity by directly directing light
to solar cells lightweight high powered
batteries that aren't built but are
grown that was neat stuff engineering
viruses to create to create batteries
more efficient lighting systems that
rely on nanotechnology innovative
engineering that will make it possible
for offshore wind power plants to
deliver electricity even when the air is
still and it's a reminder that all of
you our heirs to a legacy of innovation
not just here but across America that
has improved our health and our
well-being and helped us achieve
unparalleled prosperity I was telling
John and Duvall on the ride over here
you just get excited being here and
seeing these extraordinary young people
and the extraordinary leadership of
Professor Hockfield
because because it taps into something
essential about America it's the legacy
of daring men and women who put their
talents and their efforts into the
pursuit of discovery and it's the legacy
of a nation that supported those
intrepid few willing to take risks on an
idea that might fail but might also
change the world even in the darkest of
times that this nation has seen it has
always sought a brighter horizon think
about it in the middle of the Civil War
President Lincoln designated a system of
land-grant colleges including MIT which
helped open the doors of higher
education to millions of people
a year a full year before the end of
World War two President Roosevelt signed
the GI Bill which helped unleash a wave
of strong and broadly shared economic
growth after the Soviet launch of
Sputnik the first artificial satellite
to orbit the earth the United States
went about winning the space race by
investing in science and technology
leading not only to small steps on the
moon but also to tremendous economic
benefits here on earth so the truth is
we have always been about innovation we
have always been about discovery that's
in our DNA the truth is we also face
more complex challenges than generations
past a medical system that holds the
promise of unlocking new cures is
attached to a healthcare system that has
the potential to bankrupt families and
businesses and our government a global
marketplace that links the trader on
Wall Street to the homeowner on Main
Street to the factory worker in China an
economy in which we all share
opportunity is also an economy in which
we all share crisis we face threats to
our security that seek there are threats
to our security that are based on those
who would seek to exploit the very
interconnectedness and openness that's
so essential to our prosperity the
system of energy that powers our economy
also undermines our security and in
dangers our planet
now while the challenges today are
different we have to draw on the same
spirit of innovation that's always been
central to our success and that's
especially true when it comes to energy
there may be plenty of room for debate
as to how we transition from fossil
fuels to renewable fuels we all
understand there's no silver bullet to
do it there's going to be a lot of
debate about how we move from an economy
that's importing oil to one thats
exporting clean energy technology how we
harness the innovative potential on
display here at MIT to create millions
of new jobs and how we will lead the
world to
that the worst consequences of climate
change they're going to be all sorts of
debates both in the laboratory and on
Capitol Hill but there's no question
that we must do all these things
country's on every corner of this earth
now recognize that energy supplies are
growing scarcity energy demands are
growing larger and rising energy use
imperils the planet we will leave to
future generations and that's why the
world is now engaged in a peaceful
competition to determine the
technologies that will power the 21st
century from China to India from Japan
to Germany nations everywhere are racing
to develop new ways to produce and use
energy the nation that wins this
competition will be the nation that
leads the global economy I'm convinced
of that and I want America to be that
nation it's that simple
now that's why the Recovery Act that we
passed back in January makes the largest
investment in clean energy in history
not just to help end this recession but
to lay a new foundation for lasting
prosperity the Recovery Act includes
eighty billion dollars to put tens of
thousands of Americans to work
developing new battery technologies for
hybrid vehicles modernizing the electric
grid making our homes and businesses
more energy efficient doubling our
capacity to generate renewable
electricity these are creating private
sector jobs weatherizing homes
manufacturing cars and trucks upgrading
to smart electric meters installing
solar panels assembling wind turbines
building new facilities and factories
and laboratories all across America and
by the way helping to finance
extraordinary research in fact in just a
few weeks right here in Boston workers
will break ground on a new wind
technology testing Center a project made
possible through a twenty five million
dollar Recovery Act investment as well
as through the support of Massachusetts
and its partners and I want everybody to
understand governor Patrick's leadership
and vision make this happen he was
bragging about Massachusetts on the way
over here I told him you don't have to
be a booster I already love the state
but he helped make this happen
[Applause]
hundreds of people will be put to work
building this new testing facility but
the benefits will extend far beyond
these jobs for the first time
researchers in the United States will be
able to test the world's newest and
largest wind turbine blades blades
roughly the length of a football field
and that in turn will make it possible
for American businesses to develop more
efficient and effective turbines and to
lead a market estimated at more than two
trillion dollars over the next two
decades this grant follows other
Recovery Act investments right here in
Massachusetts that will help create
clean energy jobs in this Commonwealth
and across the country and this only
builds on the work of your governor
who's endeavored to make Massachusetts a
clean energy leader from increasing the
supply of renewable electricity to
quadrupling solar capacity to tripling
the Commonwealth's investment in energy
efficiency all of which helps to draw
new jobs and new industries now even
that's worth applause
[Applause]
now even as we're investing in
technologies that exist today we're also
investing in the science that will
produce the technologies of tomorrow the
Recovery Act provides the largest single
boost in scientific research in history
let me repeat that the Recovery Act the
stimulus bill represents the largest
single boost in scientific research in
history an increase
[Applause]
that's an increase in funding that's
already making a difference right here
on this campus and my budget also makes
the research and experimentation Tax
Credit permanent a tax credit that Spurs
innovation and jobs adding two dollars
to the economy for every dollar that it
costs and all of this must culminate in
the passage of comprehensive legislation
that will finally make renewable energy
the profitable kind of energy in America
John Kerry is working on this
legislation right now and he's doing a
terrific job reaching out across the
other side of the aisle because this
should not be a partisan issue everybody
in America should have a stake everybody
in America should have a stake in
legislation that can transform our
energy system in one that's far more
efficient far cleaner and provides
energy independence for American making
the best use of resources we have in
abundance
everything from figuring out how to use
the fossil fuels that inevitably we are
going to be using for several decades
things like coal and oil and natural gas
figuring out how we use those as cleanly
and efficiently as possible creating
safe nuclear power sustainable
sustainably grown biofuels and then the
energy that we can harness from the wind
and the waves in the Sun it is a
transformation that will be made as
swiftly and as carefully as possible to
ensure that we are doing what it takes
to grow this economy in the short medium
and long term and I do believe that a
consensus is growing to achieve exactly
that the Pentagon has declared our
dependence on fossil fuels a security
threat veterans from Iraq and
Afghanistan are traveling the country as
part of Operation free campaigning to
end our dependence on oil we have a few
of these folks here today
right there
the young people of this country that
I've met all across America they
understand that this is the challenge of
their generations leaders in the
business community are standing with
leaders in the environmental community
to protect the economy and the planet we
leave for our children the House of
Representatives has already passed
historic legislation due in large part
to the efforts of Massachusetts own Ed
Markey deserves a big round of applause
we're now seeing prominent Republicans
like Senator Lindsey Graham joining
forces with longtime leaders like John
Kerry on this issue to swiftly pass a
bill through the Senate as well in fact
the Energy Committee thanks to the work
of its chaired senator jeff Bingaman has
already passed key provisions of
comprehensive legislation so we are
seeing a convergence the naysayers the
folks who would pretend that this is not
an issue they're being marginalized but
I think it's important to understand
that the closer we get the harder the
opposition will fight and the more we'll
hear from those whose interests or
ideology run counter to the much needed
action that we're engaged in there are
those who will suggest that moving
toward clean energy will destroy our
economy when it's the system we
currently have that endangers our
prosperity and prevents us from creating
millions of new jobs they're going to be
those who cynically claim make cynical
claims that contradict the overwhelming
scientific evidence when it comes to
climate change claims whose only purpose
is to defeat or delay the change that we
know is necessary so we're gonna have to
work on those folks but understand
there's also another myth that we have
to dispel and this one's far more
dangerous because we're all somewhat
complicit in it it's far more dangerous
than any attack made by those who wish
to stand in the way of progress and
that's the idea that there's nothing or
little that we can do
it's pessimism
it's the pessimistic notion that our
politics are too broken and our people
too unwilling to make hard choices for
us to actually deal with this energy
issue that we're facing an implicit in
this argument is the sense that somehow
we've lost something important that
fighting American spirit that
willingness to tackle hard challenges
that determination to see those
challenges to the end that we can solve
problems that we can act collectively
that somehow that is something of the
past I reject that argument I reject it
because what I've seen here at MIT
because what I've seen across America
because of what we know we are capable
of achieving when called upon to achieve
it this is the nation that harnessed
electricity and the energy contained in
the atom that developed the steamboat
and the modern solar cell this is the
nation that pushed westward and looked
skyward
we have always sought out new frontiers
and this generation is no different
today's frontiers can't be found on a
map they're being explored in our
classrooms and our laboratories and our
startups and our factories and today's
pioneers are not travelling to some
far-flung place these pioneers are all
around us
the entrepreneurs and the inventors the
researchers the engineers helping to
lead us into the future just as they
have in the past this is the nation that
has led the world for two centuries in
the pursuit of discovery this is the
nation that will lead the clean energy
economy of tomorrow so long as all of us
remember what we have achieved in the
past and we use that to inspire us to
achieve even more in the future
I am confident that's what's happening
right here at this extraordinary
institution and if you will join us in
what is sure to be a difficult fight in
the months and years ahead I'm confident
that all of America is going to be
pulling in one direction to make sure
that we are the energy leader that we
need to be thank you very much everybody
god bless you god bless the United
States of America
[Music]
you